- I can't eat any bread?
- Oh!
- Now I'm scared.
- Hey, guys.
I'm Jasmine.
- Hey, I'm Katie.
- And I'm Kelly.
- I don't really know what
a food sensitivity test is.
- My first thought is that
it's a test for food allergies.
- I've been wanting to take
one for a really long time,
and I'm super excited.
According to Everlywell's website,
their food sensitivity
test checks your body's
immune response to 108 foods.
These food sensitivities
could potentially bring you
discomfort, stomach issues, fatigue,
or varying other symptoms.
It is not a food allergy test.
The results of the test serve
as a guide to help personalize
a two-phase elimination diet.
This is meant to help remove
a lot of the guesswork
in the process.
So I do think I have food sensitivities.
Since I have experimented
with diets before,
I think I have an intolerance to dairy
and definitely gluten.
- I've always wondered if
I'm sensitive to gluten.
I've taken it out before
because I have an autoimmune
disease called Hashimoto's,
and I've met a few people that have said
when they've eliminated gluten,
their Hashimoto's, like,
went away.
- I think I have a food
sensitivity to soy milk.
I am interested to see if
I'm sensitive to dairy.
I usually tell people that I'm
blessed because 95% of Asians
are lactose intolerant.
I also think I am sensitive to gluten.
I've been told many times that I am,
I've never gotten a test for it.
One time I had really bad back pain.
I went to the doctor and I was
like, yeah, it hurts so bad.
And she looks at my arm.
She's like, "Do you have eczema?"
And I was like, "Yeah, I do."
She was like, "You should
cut down on gluten."
And I was like, "But my back hurts."
- I do not want to be sensitive to cheese.
Cheese, cheese.
- Dairy.
- I'm a little skeptical about this test,
but I wonder if it's going
to be, like, super accurate.
- I'm skeptical,
not because I don't believe it,
but I, like, just kind
of don't believe it.
- Just gotta be somewhat accurate.
I don't know.
- [Director] Well, are you
excited to take the test?
- I'm excited. Let's find
out what I can't eat.
Okay, instructions.
Step one, watch video.
So I guess I'm going to do that first.
Just watched the video,
and I think I know what I need to do.
- Drink a large glass of water,
warm hands with hot water
for at least one minute,
shake your hands by your
side for 15 to 20 seconds,
and do some jumping jacks
to get extra warmed up.
- Time to prick my finger.
- I've never pricked my finger.
So we'll see how that goes.
- Ahh!
- Okay, it's not that bad.
- Now I'm scared.
- So now I'm just going to
drip my blood into the circles.
- I have to fill ten
circles with my blood.
- This is my test.
All good.
I'm gonna package this guy up.
- And mail it back to Everlywell.
- Very interested to see
how this can tell you
your food sensitivities.
- [Jasmine] I just got a text.
- The email from Everlywell has come in.
It says my results are ready.
So I guess this is just
the moment of truth.
It's gonna determine how
happy or sad I'm going to be.
I guess for the next week.
- Today is my birthday.
And I'm really hoping there's
not something on there
that's going to ruin the day.
- Three.
- Two.
- One!
- And I don't know my email.
- Hi, Jasmine.
Your food sensitivity
comprehensive test is complete.
Your test showed an IgG reactivity
above normal to 46 foods.
- You have an IgG reactive
above normal to 49 foods.
- Oh my God.
I don't have any high reactivity
to any foods or moderate.
- You didn't show high
reactivity to any foods.
Oh, I have high reactivity.
Egg whites?
Egg whites are a high reactivity?
- Moderate reactivity to seven foods.
Milk.
Egg white.
Gluten.
Pineapple, spelt, vanilla, and wheat.
Vanilla?
- Cashew, cow's milk, emmental cheese?
I don't even know if I said that right.
Often called Swiss cheese.
Oh, I love Swiss cheese.
Blue cheese?
Gluten, goat milk, pistachio,
rye, smelt, wheat, whey.
I can't eat any bread?
- Okay, let's see what my mild.
Asparagus, which is something we eat
a couple of times a week.
Bell pepper, black tea,
Brazil nut, cayenne, chicken?
That's like 50% of my diet.
- Asparagus, butter?
Butter?
- Butter?
- Casein?
- [Both] Casein is a protein,
a major component of milk.
- Okay, so they just don't want me having
any type of milk or cheese.
- Garlic?!
Oh!
- So I'm sweating.
I'm stressed.
It's definitely going to be
a week about getting creative
with your foods.
- It's still not sinking
in that I can't have
chicken, salmon, or turkey
throughout the week.
That's literally all we eat.
So I'm going to have
to get really creative.
- That's a lot of foods I eat often.
- I wonder if my autoimmune disease, like,
had anything to do with
like me having so many.
- This totally ruined my birthday.
I'm so bummed, but the good news is
I don't have to start until tomorrow,
so let's go.
- Good morning.
It's day one of cutting
out food sensitivities.
I'm actually dog-sitting today.
So I feel like being on
a diet and dog-sitting,
it's just gonna be a lot of work.
Hey, hey, hey, come back!
- I woke up ready to
take on this challenge,
but first I have to go
to the grocery store
because there's nothing in my house.
- So I'm at the grocery store right now.
I'm getting everything I need,
but the temptation is real.
Everything has garlic
or ginger or something.
I'm just going to check out.
- All right, I'm at the store,
and my game plan is to grab
as many veggies as I can
to offset all those lean
proteins I can't have.
- I just finished shopping,
and it actually was kind of expensive.
I got a lot of fruits and
vegetables, which was good,
but all of that stuff has
gotten kind of expensive.
And then I bought some things
I don't normally get like
almond butter, which is way more expensive
than just your regular old peanut butter.
I saw coffee.
I couldn't get my coffee,
so I got some tea.
I think my husband is going
to be shocked when I get home.
And like how many vegetables I bought.
- [Kelly] All right, I just
got back from the store.
So I got actual pork sausage and bacon.
I got some frozen fish
to make quick fish tacos.
I'm going to try out this
plant-based ground beef,
some pasta, some tomatoes, zucchini.
- For breakfast, I've seen
online, sweet potato toast.
So I'm going to take a sweet
potato, cut it into slices,
and I'll put that in a 400
degree oven for about 30 minutes,
where we'll toast it.
And I'm saying "toast" in quotes.
I'll put some almond butter on
top of it, slices of bananas,
a little bit of cinnamon,
and a drizzle of honey.
It actually looks really good.
I am kind of forgetting that
it's on the sweet potato,
but I'm not fully forgetting.
It's not bad.
Maybe I should've gone with
a more savory topping for the
top 'cause right now
it's just sweet on sweet.
I'm going to go start work
and chow down on the sweet potato toast.
It's a little chewier than toast.
- All right, today is
day two of the challenge.
I just got to work.
I'm about to go in.
I woke up feeling super
tired, just not motivated.
- It is a new day.
Yesterday was kind of stressful
because I was dog-sitting.
Today, I was looking through
what I recorded yesterday,
and I caught something that
really changed my mindset.
I just kept referring to this
whole food elimination process
as a diet, which like,
yes, I am changing my diet,
but telling myself that
I am now entering a diet,
just puts me in like a "Ugh!" head space.
I am catching that early.
So I'm telling myself that
this is now not a diet.
This is food elimination.
I usually start off my
morning with a green juice.
I'm adding in some kale,
green apple, some celery.
I usually add banana and ginger as well,
but I have reactivity to those foods.
So today I will be doing strawberries.
- It is day two.
I'm having lunch at work.
Got food from a Mediterranean place.
I think the fries could
be in there, like an oil.
I'm going to pretend that I don't know.
I think I could have canola oil.
It's not fried in peanut oil.
I can't have peanuts.
- [Betsy] It's not?
Are you sure?
- I don't, shh, Betsy.
- Are you sure they're
not fried in peanut oil?
- [Katie] Betsy's calling me out.
- That's very normal for fries to be...
- [Katie] No!
- All right, I'm still at work.
I just ordered salad.
I had to make a few modifications.
I got avocado instead of chicken.
And I got a cashew-based dressing
since I can't have peanuts.
Okay, the verdict is in.
This salad's delicious.
I don't miss the chicken at all.
Ten out of ten.
- Good morning.
It is day three.
I felt the morning skinnies today,
which is shocking to me
because I haven't been eating
healthy, per se.
I just have been cutting out
the foods that I'm showing
sensitivities to.
We'll say that one thing
that I was looking for was
improvement in my skin.
I'm breaking out,
but maybe it's just like
trying to get it out there.
I'm pretty much eating leftovers today.
For dinner, actually me and my boyfriend
are going to go on a date.
I am hoping that ordering
out isn't going to be
too complicated.
I was able to get popcorn,
but I can't get my, my best
friend over there, butter.
- [Jasmine's Boyfriend] Oh, thank you.
- I just got home from work.
Sitting on my couch,
and I don't want to move,
but I have to make dinner.
I would love to order out right now,
but I'm realizing that
garlic and ginger and herbs
are in, like, everything.
I guess I'll go make dinner.
I'm so tired.
Remember when I said I wasn't going to
make a separate meal for the kids?
Well.
This is my dinner for tonight.
We had some frozen bean and
cheese burritos in the freezer
that my husband had made,
salad, and I had to make my own dressing
because all the bottled
ones had garlic in it,
and then to round it all out,
of course, some tortilla chips.
- All right, good morning.
It is midweek.
And I actually woke up this
morning feeling kind of
bloated and crampy.
I don't think I ate anything
on my sensitivity list.
I did eat steak last night,
which I don't normally eat red meat.
So maybe that's why,
but since I couldn't have
chicken, I tried some steak.
Since I didn't love
that sweet potato toast,
I'm just going to be having
an avocado with hot sauce.
- I'm about halfway through
the elimination diet,
and to be honest, I'm not feeling amazing.
I don't feel bad, but I don't feel like
how I thought I would.
I thought I'd be like jumping
for moon or something.
- For breakfast today,
I'm having the green juice
that I prepped.
Yesterday was good.
I slept really well for
the first time in a while.
No bloating and goods sleep.
- All right, it is
lunchtime, and I'm starving.
And I'm going to treat myself to a BLT,
and I'm going to serve it
with some basil mayonnaise
to take it up a notch.
So the first step is to cook the bacon,
and I'm going to do that
in a cast iron skillet,
over medium heat.
And as you can see, I cut the slices.
So not only do they cook faster,
but they'll cook more evenly.
So now that my bacon is done,
I have removed it from my pan.
I've taken out some of the bacon drippings
and left a little bit in,
and then I'm going to toast
my bread in the rest of it.
Next step is to make some
of that basil mayonnaise
I was talking about.
We're going to start with
a little bit of mayonnaise,
juice of half a lemon,
all that fresh basil,
a little Aleppo pepper,
just to spice things up.
And just a splash of
water to get everything
going in the blender.
First I'm gonna spread a generous dollop,
then I'm going to add some
beautiful tomato slices,
some lettuce, and then the best part.
I mean, bacon, hello?
Let's put that other slice on.
Oh my God.
I don't know about you,
but I think the messier the sandwich is,
the better it tastes.
Like, this thing is dripping.
- I'm filming again today at work.
Betsy, what are we making?
- [Betsy] Banana bread!
- [Katie] And I can't eat any of it.
- Obviously I had to go for a Boba stop.
I usually get a milk tea,
but because I can't have
cow's milk right now,
I went with a fruit slush.
- I'm out to dinner with
my husband and kids,
and normally I try to be healthy
and get the turkey burger,
but tonight I'm going to treat
myself and get the actual
beef burger because it's
all I can have anyways.
Good morning.
It is time for another
Kelly car confessional.
How I'm feeling, honestly, not that great.
My acid reflux is like
at an all time high.
I'm waking up super bloated.
I'm burping.
It's not cute.
I'm not used to eating
like red meats and pork.
I don't know if my body's
in shock and it's like,
what are you doing to me?
I think maybe I need to be a
little more conscious about
just not eating red meat and pork.
- At this point in the
process, I am pretty surprised.
I was the only one that was skeptical
about the food sensitivity test.
After speaking with Katie and Kelly,
the food elimination
process seems to be working
the best for me.
We are on set today, so we had
to pick our dish from a menu,
which it's a little harder.
I got a spicy pork rice bowl,
and I'm sure that if it's
flavorful, it has garlic in it.
And that egg roll wrap
definitely has gluten in it.
Some days you just got
to call your losses.
- Today, we're all eating together,
and I'm cheating.
I'm having chicken banh mi,
and I feel great about it.
- [Jasmine] Woo!
- Having work lunch today.
- No regrets.
- What'd you do?
- I'm vlogging.
- [Katie] I'm vlogging.
Kelly, are you vlogging?
- Don't look at me, I'm cheating.
- I'm cheating too.
- [Katie] You're both cheating?
- I am not cheating.
I got a steak salad with
everything I can eat on it.
- That sucks.
- It's going to be delicious.
- [Kelly] For dinner tonight,
the kids got boxed mac
and cheese and broccoli,
and to make it an adult meal for myself,
I'm cooking up some bacon.
I'm going to add some mushrooms,
saute those up in the bacon fat.
Throw in some spinach
and mix all together.
This looks pretty good.
I already took a bite
'cause I couldn't wait.
It's so good.
- I just got home from work,
and Chris, he's making me stuffed pepper.
- This no-garlic thing
is driving me insane.
I didn't know how hard it would be
to live without garlic,
let me freaking tell you.
So for dinner today,
I am having Korean beef patties,
steamed Chinese broccoli,
topped with some scallion
oil, and of course,
a small bowl of rice.
I just added tamari, sesame
oil, Korean chili flakes,
brown sugar, and mirin.
Mix that all together.
Then folded in some chopped scallions.
Pan fried them on a skillet.
Cheers.
Tastes like Korean barbecue.
I do miss the garlic though.
- Good morning, everyone.
As you guys know,
I had that big bowl of pasta last night,
and I woke up feeling pretty bad.
My stomach is protruding out.
I feel bloated, it's cramping.
I just don't feel great.
And I know it's because it
was that gluten in the pasta,
even though the test said
I could have those things,
my body is having adverse
reactions to these foods,
and I just know they
don't make me feel well,
and I know that I
shouldn't be eating them.
- I am on my last night
of the elimination diet,
and I'm going to try
some red lentil penne.
I have never had this pasta before.
If it's good, that's going
to be pretty exciting.
The lentil pasta is finished cooking.
Hmm.
That's actually pretty good.
It doesn't have the spring.
It's al dente, but then as you chew it,
it kind of crumbles and
breaks up in your mouth.
It's good.
But I'm excited that I get to
start incorporating some of my
favorite foods back in next week.
- I am re-introducing my food sensitivity,
starting with gluten.
I actually don't think it'll
take up to four days for me
to see a result.
Because I'm about five bites in,
and I'm already feeling gassy.
Cheers!
I'm happy.
Whatever happens, this
moment, remember it.
I had a lot of gluten yesterday.
I had a whole plate of pasta.
My eczema started flaring up.
I was gassy, and I was
sweating a lot in my sleep.
Like, I got hot flashes.
- Last night, I had the
salmon for the first time,
and I woke up at 4:00 AM in the worst pain
I've felt in a really long time.
My stomach was cramping.
It was bloating.
It almost felt like I had food poisoning.
I think it was just me
having a reaction to salmon.
And I really do have a food sensitivity,
but it really was crazy to
see my body react in that way
and feel it in a real physical way
because I really hadn't felt any different
when I was eliminating.
Now I get it.
I get it.
- Okay, so it's my first
day of re-introducing back
some of the foods.
I'm going to start with an egg.
I cracked an egg, added
some salt and pepper.
Here we go.
I love eggs so much.
I'm going to see how I feel in two days,
or if anything happens
between now and two days,
and we'll see if eggs was an issue.
So it's been two days
since I've had an egg,
and I feel completely fine.
I don't know.
Today, I've added back in coffee,
and it tastes so good.
So I'm just going to keep
adding back in these foods
one by one and just seeing
how I react to them.
Overall, I have mixed feelings
about doing this test.
I think removing a lot of my
carbs and a lot of the sugars
I'm eating and just kind
of the indulgent stuff
I've been having made me feel better.
It gave me more energy,
but I don't think it
pinpointed to having like
a food sensitivity necessarily.
- So overall, this is a great process,
and it's always a journey to
learn more about your own body.
- It was an interesting week.
It was an interesting challenge,
and I'm just glad I got
to do it with my friends.
- [Jasmine's Boyfriend] Oh, yes!